welcome back to the cool onesie I have
the same Lindsey really yeah yummy man
you guys should get one too the undies
is an awesome sponsor of the podcast and
they're the provider of these wonderful
pumpkin me on me of these onesies we are
wearing the softest most comfortable
onesies that money can buy as well as
the underwear to boot and mandy's is
incredible three times soft in the
cotton you should try it it's the only
way to believe it got to put it on your
body go to meet undies comm slash Jen
and Julian get 15% off and free shipping
100% satisfaction guarantee
also what a great gift for the holidays
more later on that also guys calm is the
app that helps you relax de-stress help
yourself sleep help reduce anxiety
guided meditation I mean it goes on and
on but it's an incredible app that you
can download right now but going to calm
calm /n and Julien that's C ALM calm and
you get a 25% off of the compromiso
description which is a really awesome
service I use the app all the time
genuinely I pop in my headphones and I
listen to the daily calm anytime I can
and it is it's really nice it is a great
app that helps a lot of things with your
brain but namely it's really good for
helping yourself get some sleep so check
it out or hit the link below and try it
out see how it works Thank You Spontini
it's funny because we're kind of
matching with marble because he's my mom
he's laying on his orange bed you want
to face them Bobby
show us your little face bring that face
now you turned around Wow currents so
nice
Oh Kermit Kermit's got some he's got
some medical issues going on right now
he's fine everything's fine shocked
aren't y'all but we were at the vet
earlier today you know he had been he'd
been crying a lot and I know that
sounds like everything is normal for
crema it is because he cries normally
and but you know we sort of realized it
was a little bit more than normal yeah
and we think it's attributed to his
teeth which we our teeth out but also we
noticed he has these things on his nails
my god little infections listen to me
okay
this dog I'm telling you is so nasty
like we've considered the fact that
maybe this could potentially be like a
side effect of his medicine or something
that he takes her his Cushing's disease
I don't know but we noticed that one of
his nails like it almost looks like his
nail is dying like it's discolored and
it's like gross so he how look at the
nail bed like right where it meets his
paw and it looked a little infected like
it looked a little red and I was looking
like oh don't make it too gross by the
way I don't want to gross people out
okay I'll try but it is so disgusting so
I looked at his other paw and he had
like a black ball like on the inside of
the same toe on the other foot so we
were like alright tomorrow morning we're
gonna go take him to the vets we took
him to the vet this morning and she was
sort of like oh you know you can get in
here and clean off this like crusty
stuff around the nail bed like I'll give
him some antibiotics some medicated
wipes and I bring him home and I'm
looking at this like ball and I'm like
that looks like something like a like a
pimple like a blackhead like I
discussing like he gets it's like they
have this like bizarre gross like tissue
paper thin skin that gets very irritated
and he gets like zits like a person like
Oh for his body and I'm looking at it
and I'm like it looks so painful because
it's right on his nail bed like it's
like a big you know it looks painful so
I'm like you know what that looks like
something I could probably help him get
out the most disgusting thing I've ever
seen
so disgusting but what's weird is that
he has it on the same it's two toes the
outside toe and the inside toe on every
single hand like right along sometimes
on the inside sometimes on the top
sometimes
like but they're just filled with like
black tar that is like inside of his paw
it's like a little tiny cyst but it's
like little sis I would think because he
doesn't do anything different than the
other dogs and his environment is
exactly the same he gets fed the same I
would think it has to be his Cushing's
or the medic medication he takes for it
because otherwise it seems like a weird
random thing or it's just Kermit being
very high V and special about it but I
mean the the one is definitely like a
little more infected than the others so
I think that one actually is really
hurting him but like the I went and
checked on all his other toes and sure
enough he has this like gross like you
have to lift up the hair and like look
under there like a gross no black cysts
of just pure disgusting tar that will
come out when you just sort of like
touch it and squeeze it out it's so
disgusting Julian what's like I was like
can you can you help me just like pet
him like distract him a little you know
cuz he does really well when we do that
look what we cut his nails you distract
them because it's really still and um I
was like can you come help me and he's
just really just like this is disgusting
this is so disgusting like I've
expressed their anal glands before okay
this is really gross okay yeah it's
really disgusting and it's just carmit
like I looked at there none of the mouse
none of the other dogs have it it's just
Kermit hmm so we gave him some
medication on top of that TLC in-person
treatment that Jenna has been giving him
but on top of that he's unfortunately
gonna have to get a couple more teeth
out so he'll be going under for that
probably in the next couple of weeks or
something people ask like with marbles
too it's it's sort of a genetic thing
their mouths are very small it's not
uncommon Kermit's coming up on ten years
old that's how old marble was when he
got all his teeth out or the rest of his
teeth oh yeah but they they just get
nasty plaque in there and you can do
your best so small brush and clean yo
yeah it's just very difficult especially
when they escalate an age and there's
just they're so crowded yeah peaches I
mean teaches next on the list too
because she's got one or two that are
pretty bad but so that was her day today
we well we noticed that last night we
woke up
today and spent the day at the vet with
Kermit California is on fire I know like
every single day there's a new fire it's
actually horrifying and I have seen a
fair amount of tweets and people
reaching out asking like are we okay and
be safe and first of all thank you for
your concern right now we're safe right
now we're out of range of all the fires
although it's been getting closer than
we'd like like it really really too
close for comfort a lot of these
different smaller fires that have popped
up so there was the TIC fire which was
in like Santa Clarita which is north of
us that's fair fair bit of ways away
from us now that we're in the valley the
same Valley Santa Clarita so we get that
air so when the fires happen out there
we get that air but we're far enough
away to where we're not actually you
know in danger of evacuating or whatever
then there was a fire much closer to our
house and then there was the getti fire
today the getti fire is always [ __ ]
scary because first of all the Getty
Museum is a legendary like Museum and
it's on top of this mountain that
literally if the mountain burns the
Gettys going up in flames
yeah and it's actually currently being
fought right now like as we record so
which is really terrifying because I
grew up in Southern California and the
Getty was you know it's the Getty it's
like it's such a landmark and there's
those videos of people driving through
the you know that section of the 405
we're like the hills are like on fire
and it just looks like apocalyptic but
you know hopefully that can get
contained the air quality isn't really
horrible for for us from that fire it's
kind of blowing the other way towards
the ocean but as of right now we are
we're safe from the fires we're not
evacuating we came sort of close to
evacuating but no longer in danger of
that right now we have our go bag our
emergency bag ready to go and we're just
we're keeping an eye on the news but I
will say we did a stream last week and
if you weren't there for it I just
wanted to bring it up the ticke fire in
Santa Clarita was so close to the gentle
barn which is the animal sanctuary that
I've gone to many times Jenna's been -
I've sponsored animals I've made videos
about it
we habitat to [ __ ] up I have a tattoo of
a cow I met at the Gentle Barn really
wonderful people like doing amazing
things to help animals and you know
at-risk youth but they had to evacuate
the entire barn like the whole farm was
in like literally across the street from
the fire and they have hundreds of
animal hunts of animals some huge like
horses donkey
pigs cows and some smaller like chickens
smaller pigs yes
so they with the help of I'm sure so
many people from the community who had
trucks and trailers and they actually
have like a I don't know what it's
called like a safety location where they
all evacuated - yeah
and luckily as of right now they had
evacuated all the animals safely gotten
to a place where they could eat and and
sleep and everything and the evacuation
was lifted but during the time of the
evacuation we did a stream where we
raised some money to help them out so
anyone who stopped by that stream thank
you guys thank you guys for supporting
and for you know we really did a lot
yeah you guys did a lot for that which
was really really rad but those are all
volunteers those are all people that go
out there in their own free will and
desire to go bring those trailers to
help with those animals and yeah they
could use every help every resource that
they could get yeah and Ellie and J the
people who run it are two of the best
people ever and you know actually the
fires if you hear me continuously clear
my throat I'm fairly certain it's
because of the air it sort of felt like
that ever since I don't know a week or
so ago like a week some fires started
you like you get like a lump in your
throat yeah like doing that I'm not sick
anymore so I'm not sick either but it's
like you feel it yeah so we're just
we're just choking on ash over here hell
yeah California be like I'm on fire so
hopefully I mean also you know huge
shout out to all the amazing
firefighters in California and Southern
California who have to deal with this
[ __ ] during crazy fire seasons and
and we're open everybody's so safe and
yeah their homes and their lives yeah I
know it's a lot and it's very close to
us like the highways are shut down a lot
of ways mm-hmm yeah so how do I get
around not that we have to go that way
but yeah but still did you see that UCLA
like the fires like right there I saw a
student tweet like from what looked like
their dorm room or something on campus
and it was like um UCLA you gonna say
anything and the fires like moving down
towards campus it's so close and they
had tweeted out like just two hours of
those like oh yeah if you can't get to
school that's okay but we expect
employees so be on campus
no no that's well like all of the
schools over the hill are there having a
fire day there's no school yeah so that
yeah if you're in an emergency and your
school says something I'm like mmm I'm
gonna do what I feel is right thanks so
much I'm pretty sure I can explain to my
teacher why I didn't feel comfortable
driving to class today thank you I don't
give a [ __ ] with my school yeah it's
just dangerous I mean it's not safe so
yeah hopefully uh all this will die down
soon I mean it's literally yesterday was
the first day I can remember in recent
memory at all that was even remotely not
blazing hot it's November in a couple of
days and it's been hot all the way
through October it's just scary but what
at my point is is that the weather is
starting to cool down which is good it's
good for you know fire fire season and
it's good for like my sanity because I
miss the winter months I need some cool
weather and you'll put on a hoodie every
once in a while not just be sweating I
don't
I'm good with no no you appreciate it
appreciate it but I'm good without it
you really wanted to be 95 every day so
we're snowed in with heat I don't care
no you do care okay I care what I
thought you know you're tired of the
heat - I mean yeah be nice to have a
numpy so sweltering but I don't really
care if it gets cold cuz you come from
the snow yeah moved to California I'm
having a great time okay
ain't nobody got time for snow
I'm well you like it I kind of want snow
I know you like so there's many people
that like snow I'm not one of those
[ __ ] people did you ever at one point
in your life say snow is dope even when
you're yet like the first snow of the
season like the pretty one you know and
it's like falling slowly and it's really
magic powder that's a great time if it
snows on Christmas Day but like not too
much that's a great time the rest of it
the snow that falls in March can [ __ ]
off the snow that falls in May can [ __ ]
off I don't review brother he's like
disgusting
we're just gonna sit in your gutter for
like months on end [ __ ] right off out of
here
that's how I feel about it being 95
degrees on October 28th I understand I
think that there's some people that
don't understand that but I do
understand like you made the comparison
it's like being snowed in
it does get exact yeah we can't like you
go outside and can't be outside they
can't walk the dogs can't it's just like
yeah man hasn't been that hot right this
I can't lean on yeah but anyway this is
just me ranting about good weather being
ungrateful good smile thanks I've been
working on it hmm
tell us why you jujitsu tournament Julie
he's villainous significant amount of
pain I'm a little sore so he's having
trouble dressing himself um I did I
competed in a jujitsu competition
yesterday I didn't win but I had a
pretty great experience and I I decided
to compete like three months ago and so
with that decision I was like okay you
know I've never really done this what
what do I need to do so I I kind of me
and my trainer my strength and
conditioning coach the one that we go to
train together we develop sort of like a
plan and a program for me to like get
all my cardio and all my everything kind
of dialed in for the training to come to
compete and so we did all that for three
months I trained really hard in jujitsu
I
I worked on everything I could and you
know putting the hours and I documented
a lot of it and I'm excited because from
sort of the start to the finish which
was yesterday I documented my experience
what it was like has like a very casual
adult who is a hobbyist in jujitsu
decided to compete for the first time
and and I know there's a like I've
competed in a noogie tournament like
many many years ago but that was
actually before I really trained so I'm
not even really counting that and also
it was noogie so I it's not the same but
I'm gonna be putting out a video and I'm
excited because it's sort of like an
opportunity for me to share like a real
intense experience that I went through
on my youtube channel and I think that's
a fun thing and I'm actually really
looking forward to editing it because
it's sort of like a long-form
documentary style vlog which i think is
cool and exciting for me because I don't
do that stuff a lot but in short it was
great it was a great experience
I tested myself I put myself in a very
strange intense high-pressure
environment and I did it you know and
I'm I'm pretty sore I'm a little beat up
I got bopped on the head kind of good I
thought I was concussed for a little bit
might have like a minor concussion I had
my arm almost taken off your brother got
is not really so I'm still recovering
and but overall I mean it was a very
amazing experience and one of the things
about jiu-jitsu and I think Jenna and a
couple of our friends and family who
were there yesterday kind of could see
for the first time is like when you're
in an environment where you know
jiu-jitsu is happening you meet people
and you come in contact with people who
are in general just really good nice
people
yeah and they there's this really strong
like palpable mutual respect yeah I
think someone had said to us that there
were 900 people that competed at this
tournament it was not an ego in the room
no no I mean that's who that's jiu-jitsu
kind of like in a nutshell it's you meet
these people and like I was going
against I was humbling this board I was
at the I was at the bottom of my weight
class
I weigh I weighed in I stepped on the
scale yesterday with my 3 pound Gyan at
200 pounds and the weight class goes up
to 2 of 7 sounds of the very I was the
lightest guy in my division by a good
pound or two and I went against two
different guys one of them technically
sound about but you know about my height
and you know played a really great game
and the other one literally was Peyton
Manning he was like 6 foot 5 and he
looked like pain he did and he played a
great game and he BB too and um you know
what I I got to talk with him afterwards
which is cool and I learned that both of
them compete regularly regularly and you
know travel and their their competitor
jiu-jitsu players whereas I'm I'm a
hobbyist and this was my competition
debut so there's a lot a lot of little
nuggets of jujitsu knowledge and more so
than that there were a lot of life life
lessons and moments for me to kind of
learn and reflect on yesterday and also
moving forward and that I'm very
grateful for and the one of the coolest
things was having you there
our friend Lexi came out our trainers
Dustin and Carolyn who run detox fitness
wonderful wonderful people who had been
helping me so much prepare both my
training but also within me to recovery
I've been doing so the thing about
brother and sister were there as well my
brother and sister indeed yep and it was
just it was my point is it was like it I
could have gone to this alone and it
would have been just as special to me
but having a group of you know your
people there cheering you on is is a
feeling though that never ever gets old
coming from playing high school baseball
and forgetting what that felt like I
know I will say so we trained together
at detox with Dustin and they came up
with this very comprehensive plan of
working on Jillian's cardio and like
lifting Dustin made me train like you
for what two months yeah we walk in
there right we already do some [ __ ]
circuits I'm [ __ ] tired and like I'm
not I'm not there to complain but I will
make jokes to like trying it out just
right so Julian Hill astronaut shoulder
is because he has you know you're
occurring like injury from back in the
day uh Olympic lifting and he always be
like you know just totally feeling and
I'm like oh I'm in mines really heart
and I don't know
we go in there we're like we're doing
stuff we're hitting it pretty hard and
he has us doing these like seven-minute
circuits to prepare Julian's cardio for
a 7-minute round of jiu-jitsu
so you know we'll do seven stations each
is a minute long you go as hard as you
can for seven minutes then we'll take a
break and do it again and then we die
over and over and over again for months
we're just dying on one day dustin be
like alright y'all grab the battle rope
so you guys know what paddle ropes are
there's just like big heavy ropes that
you go like this and you can do
different things with he goes doing for
you seven minutes and I was like you
sick [ __ ] what the hell is this it
whatever did bellerose are seven minutes
in a row I'm a 33 year old lady that
just comes in here and move my bodies if
I didn't I won't move it why do I have
to do battle ropes for seven minutes in
a row anyways so Julian's training for
tiny vinyl or anyway Julian's training
for his jiu-jitsu competition but I'm
hoping eventually that Dustin will cater
the workouts to my specific needs which
are eSports athlete and when I get
signed
when I get signed I will be Dustin's
only professional current athlete thank
you very much I'm gonna do a lot of
risks exercises a lot of finger
exercises you're just gonna go into the
gym and sit in a gaming chair for six
hours and he's just gonna like push you
around you're gonna have to like scoot
back to the desk but you know I've been
doing the same training as you I'm not
the same I some of the same hey chill I
don't push myself nearly it's hard cuz I
ain't gotten to you know what I'm sayin
Julian's like wearing a weight vest he's
like really hitting it hard and I'm just
like I'm just gonna go my own pace no
but he does make me do the same things
as you I just do him slower
mm-hmm I'm not in there to kill myself
you know yeah
yes Julian it was really really really
cool the last time that I'd seen you
compete was when you did your Olympic
weightlifting competition which was
really cool to watch and you worked so
hard for that and it was just it's
always inspiring and I said this to
Julian on the way home in the cars like
whenever you watch another grown adult
push themselves outside of their comfort
zone and do something to compete like it
really really doesn't matter if you had
won every single match if you had loss
every single match like what's so cool
and inspiring to even be there is to
just watch someone that you love and
care about do a fulfill a personal goal
you know and it's that's what makes that
sport so special is that you do it you
know multiple times per week you do it
at your gym that you love with the
people that you care about there you
love that space and it's a life sport
like you said that they have a group
older 45 and older for starters called
masters and those people only do jitsi
chowder in competition your group is 18
to 35 adult and there's a younger age
than that I think it's adult masters and
masters that ultra masters ultra master
I think that's always call it might be
wrong but it's it's the division above
masters age wise where it's like I think
fifty first of all I love that they
called a mess amazing beautiful ten out
of ten but like that's how the age
groups are broken up like this is truly
a life sport and none of it requires you
to ever compete like you can enjoy
jiu-jitsu at a gym and learn it and love
it and do it for your entire life and
never compete it's one aspect of the
sport and you do the I go in there and I
just love the sport and I just love
choking grown men which you know I don't
understand but I respect you so much and
this was just a thing that you could do
that was just so cool like you to push
yourself and go and compete and do it it
was just so cool to watch and I know
like obviously everyone wants to win
whenever they compete but like I'm just
standing there and Dustin and Carolyn
and you're brother and sister and Randy
and Lexie and we're all just like could
not be more proud of you in that room in
that space in that moment and that's
what makes jiu-jitsu so cool
in general it's like though all of those
fights could have gone either way you
guys are both the same belt the same way
and it's it's such a humbling sport like
someone just gets an advantage to get a
whatever I'm bad at terms you know but
that's why there is no like Kobe Bryant
of jiu-jitsu walking around like his
[ __ ] don't sink like he can get caught
anytime and choked at any moment yeah it
happens yeah that's why it like the
culture of sport in jiu-jitsu is just so
like lovely to be here
yeah I agree and thank you for saying
all that it means a lot it does so you
know I think normally you know I'm that
I'm the type of person that had I not
been you know making videos for the last
however many years and sharing my life
with you and enjoying the process of
documenting you know this is this would
have been the type of thing that I would
sign up for trained for compete and move
on with my life and take those lessons
with me and you know but I I feel
fortunate that I get to share it and
that's what I'm excited about like I
wanted to talk about on the podcast a
little bit and I tweeted about it just
so you guys know because I know a few of
you heard me talking about it from time
to time so yep I did it it's over but
the video is I'm excited and I'm excited
to relive it through editing it and I
don't know it was it was good it was
good I feel I feel sufficiently pushed
mm-hmm you know and now I'm ready to
take a week and chill and play some
video and some food and then maybe you
know get back out there so we'll
definitely get back out there in terms
of training but maybe get back out there
in terms of competing again so I just
feel jealous like we've talked about
this before I have no real like thing to
compete in you know and I would love to
compete so it's fun you a bowling league
I'm really good at bowling would you
compete in the bowling league boy you
[ __ ] know it beats competitive one
what what's it
there's non-competitive bowling leagues
yeah Oh like the ones where you grab
beers and yeah can you grab yours the
competitive one probably using wings I
mean it's like yeah if you're a
professional baseball player while
you're playing boy you stick I hate you
well when I was on my bowling team in
high school you were allowed to order
food if you want that's amazing yeah
that's me the girls on my bowling team
were such nice [ __ ] people and they
would order like mozzarella sticks and
you know you're like sixteen you don't
have any [ __ ] money and you're like
you can have some mozzarella sticks I'm
like that's so [ __ ] nice of you
what cue what is it called when you get
three strikes in a row a turkey and what
does that look like a 3x right similar
to help me undies is three times softer
recon do not use my high school bowling
experience for me undies is three times
softer than cotton not twice as soft
three times softer like three strikes
and roll oxy a turkey it's a softer
turkey in bowling turkeys are soft their
song yeah your felt their little neck
thing yeah scratchy scratch they have
amazing onesies which is one of my
favorite things that they make but they
also have the best underwear in
existence and what a great holiday gift
if you guys are looking or thinking of
what to get your loved ones oh you were
in the bralette oh the spooky bralette
guys think about me and he's for people
on your holiday list okay and the best
part besides me and these wonderful
products is that they deliver straight
to your door with free shipping so if
you think of a loved one a family member
a special someone that you want to get
some me and he's for why not spend a
little bit on me and he's for the
holidays and and show him that you love
him with that there was his there's his
his hurts it hurts them in them then
they have them in his they have matching
pairs of what she's saying they and
sizes extra small to 4 XL okay
it is literally the best thing next to
being naked and it's appropriate like
you won't get arrested because you're
not naked not they moving on also guys
go to me undies dot-com slash agenda
join 4:15
sent off and free shipping hundred
percent satisfaction guarantee also cozy
up with their new robes for men and
women which we haven't touched yet Amy
Andes come on
check it out or hit the link down below
also the wonderful calm app helps so
many things the calm app is an app that
you download and it has guided
meditation it has the daily common it
has exercises for your brain that help
you relax de-stress help you get better
sleep help you wind down after the day
help you start up for a day and they
have different focuses on their
practices from day to day which is
really great it's not very repetitive
you don't feel like you're listening to
the same copy or whatever it's not it's
not like they're just kind of copying
pacing it from each day you get kind of
new lessons all the time and I think
that's really cool they have different
focuses for their practices and it
reminds me a lot of when I used to do
yoga all the time which I would love to
get back into at some point because yoga
is so great for your mind and it helps
you de-stress and this is bringing you
that part of yoga that I remember that
it's like someone talking you through
clearing your head and being not only
clearing ahead but also being aware of
what's in your head and what you're
thinking of and that is such a huge part
of mindfulness and being able to
de-stress and in a way meditate but also
just be mindful of what's going on in
your brain it helps it helps so much
especially when we're all on our devices
all the time which is not a bad thing
I'm I'm a proponent of devices I love
screens okay but I think in in in
accompaniment of that the calm app is a
great thing so right now if you go to
calm calm CA LM calm / Jenna Julian
you can join 40 million others who have
downloaded the app and use that URL you
get 25% off a comprehensive scription
check it out hit the link below let us
know how you like it the end
thank you spine anyway we have to look
into local bowling leagues I know we
talked about judo but that seems to be
more of a task I would do it I would
still do judo I just haven't done it I
have to look I haven't even looked have
you looked up at judo school no why not
as hard I'm not I'm not getting [ __ ] I'm
scared I've never done a martial art
before but have done a bowling before
there are a few things I golf I'm good
at golf no you're not excuse you I'm not
good at golf
well you never golfed a whole round what
are you talking about have you golf with
me
I've non golf with you oh then you've
never called you're toxic I'm not toxic
I don't know you what about all the
stories I would tell you about my dad
taking us golfing and then he would get
mad at me because I said my Tamagotchi
was gonna die or that I would go to the
water hazard and catch frogs that's
catching frogs that's playing golf
that's catching frogs with your
Tamagotchi played golf the entire time
all right I apologize I didn't I didn't
mean to say you're not gonna go up your
grey golf your talks
I'm not toxic we've been to the driving
range together no you I've never played
around with you is what I'm saying you
just said I said I'm good at golf you
said no you're not you're tops all right
that was toxic I didn't know I didn't
know you're a beast at golf I'm sorry
tell me am I good at hitting balls of
the driving range yeah you can hit so
what the hell is that is more than the
driving range I understand that but you
toxic what about mini golf you've seen
my short game okay
mini golf is not golf you've seen my
short game such great with some practice
you'll get there there's too many colors
and exciting things to have a really
serious short game during mini golf it's
not a good exam you know why you
wouldn't be good at golf is because you
don't like getting up early rude rude
rude well now we need to go play golf
together so you can eat it well every
time I get invited by a friend is like
8:00 a.m. tee time on Sunday you're like
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
why don't we just go at noon because
it's busy at noon yeah because people
don't want to go ATM be the stupid
sacrifice you make to go home no what is
it there's plenty of nicely speaking for
myself yes it is boy I don't have to
golf at 8:00 a.m. yeah you know you can
come golf with me I'm gonna show you
that I'm good at golf and we're gonna do
it at noon here's what you're gonna do
no you're gonna wait in line behind
three different parties who are all very
slow you're gonna be in a foursome with
random people you're gonna
walk half the way through the first hole
waiting for them to finish on the green
you're gonna get to the green you can
hit your ball and it's gonna be another
30-minute wait before you tee off on the
hole - how does that sound book that's
like it's seven hour day you gotta go
early dude sorry for being rude you're
probably really good at golf do you know
what I used to do when I was a kid
golf Julian what no yes yes but no okay
I didn't like using irons and wedges or
putters and I was like a hole I know
some people who like to part with their
driver it worked for me I really like
how did you hit out of like out of the
rough or off the fairway with the driver
softer with more intention who's who let
you use their driver like that I got a
little one cuz I was a kid oh I have an
extra set of clubs we should go hit the
links bag too big for me no you took up
don't tell me to choke up one of us
finish our college career toxic I'm not
toxic no toxic you're very talkative you
know no I'm being painted out as a bad
guy when really okay I'm sorry I'm sorry
for saying you're not gonna call I
didn't mean it like that like I just had
never played with you so I just assumed
that you'd been to the driving yeah but
you go to the driving range like it's
different I don't know I just never a
golf with you so I'm sorry I don't have
like an athletic golf swing at all I
never said anything about your
athletically
I never said I never commented I don't
grow anymore
really okay mmm you know cuz I'm not
good at hand-to-hand combat you think
I'm not enough cuz we're gonna do what
we're gonna turn the grill bound gonna
just go to simmer okay he called me and
it's too high what the heck but call me
an ass I'll have you know that I'm
getting signed any day now in eSports
I'm also an athlete along with being a
personal physical in real life athlete
thank you okay fair enough you are
better than me can you do a handstand no
gay with these shoulders get [ __ ]
right can you yes you do backflip
yeah
do it no no I haven't done one like just
on solid ground in many years for good
reason you know we should do what I do I
should go tumbling no here's why we're
not going tumbling tumbling we wait we
went to the trampoline place and you
hurt your ankle
almost immediately yeah those are
trampolines those are menaces to society
how do you think you learn how to tumble
on pads on pads yeah you run around it's
like a gymnasium but it's soft yeah you
can do that but you also learned how to
flip on trampolines okay I hurt my ankle
on a trampoline because they have
trampolines angled at 45 degrees like
monsters okay I grew up with the
trampoline in my backyard that was flat
I was very familiar with that level that
plane of existence which is zero degrees
I'm good with that
that's that's like the ground just
bouncy when it's like this I remember
exactly how I hurt how did you do that
we were at the trampoline place this was
like two three four or five years ago I
don't [ __ ] know I'm getting old
everything and funding together I ran up
I was like oh they have angled
trampolines I'm gonna go and do a
backflip off of one so I run up I jump
off of the flat one push off of the
angled one thinking I'm gonna go [ __ ]
airborne I'm gonna do a flip I do a flip
but because it's it's not like it's a
weird angle it's almost like a wall it's
it's not 45 it's like it's like that
right and so I hit it and instead of
like bouncing and going up I went and I
tried to fit in a whole rotation in that
little mm-hm
and I landed on my ankle wonky yeah
that's why we're not going tumbling no
I'm good at tumbling probably no you're
not what do you know not exactly these
feel good exactly all right I get it I'm
sorry I said you weren't gonna golf I'm
sorry I'm sorry you're probably gonna
hurt your ankle if we go tumbling right
settled I love you
we've both seen you've seen me golf and
I've seen here to help okay
I just agree that there's room for
improvement on both ends fair enough
nobody's bad no umifriend tumbler you
don't need much of it from the golf
you're probably good to go at least I
don't work myself the entire time you
know if you're hurting yourself you know
in sports and athletics that just means
you're trying
very hard that is so no I'm gonna coach
Little League someday and listen Jared
you didn't push yourself miss your legs
aren't broken after practice we need
some ice
nobody you guys didn't work hard enough
geez Oh terrible ever have a really bad
coach Oh should be named dropped them
hell yes [ __ ] put him on blast baby
just [ __ ] hate it he was pretty awful
but it makes like good coaches even
better that's true that's true
just like wonderful that's real good
coach that's out the bad coaches for
making the good coaches look better and
y'all still suck damn mmm we had a coach
one time where we all he was
collectively like very not liked and
then that season he left after the
season and moved to a school that we
played and then we played them it just
dominated them and it was one of the
most satisfying things ever nice oh you
didn't start me last season okay I feel
like that the coaches that I've really
disliked there it's not because I think
that they're a bad coach you know I
think you can disagree with your coach
it's because they were bad people yeah
just are also just well it's sort of
like some people have their minds set in
certain ways and they're not willing to
budge though they have these egos or
these stepping thing about them there
were they're there the coach so don't
you know it's the there's the final say
and that's not what a good coach is I
don't think that's one of the things
that I think your coach should be better
at but yeah you're right I think there's
[ __ ] guys yeah mine was because they
were bad people there but it's also it's
kind of scary when you're a
student-athlete and your whole team you
know your coaches the end-all be-all
kind of they're like whatever they say
goes and there's things that go on that
are morally wrong and your only option
really is to reach out to your athletic
director and if your athletic director
doesn't have your back or believe you or
care then it's you feel very powerless
that's tough yeah I just thought of
something why we should go golfing and
make it a video that'd be a funny video
would it be funny or would it be amazing
well both cuz I'm good at golf can I use
that driver the whole time no yeah
yes you can do whatever you wanna do I
have to wear a collared shirt
no where the [ __ ] you think I'm golfing
country clubs when we were kids you had
to like even shitty golf places they
really dress like a dick you can't wear
like why not well you probably couldn't
wear this it's probably could wear this
wonderful soft me Andy's onesie I dress
oh you dick all the time no no no you
can you can just up at one level to pee
on the golf course you don't need to
wear a collar though I don't think most
places enlist that's not you most most
places around here that are not private
courses you do not maybe like a maybe
like a polo but you don't need anything
crazy it's not like I thought there had
to be a collar on your shirt
doesn't know it's not universal I guess
I haven't been golfing since the 90s so
I got a hold him on one time do you
really yeah that's amazing it's pretty
crazy I got it on a par three course
well my god I was so mad at me really
yeah I suggest the man to wash
everyone's balls at all the ball washing
stage it's pretty satisfying yeah yeah
yeah it was this tiny little course I
used to go to when I was younger its par
three course you didn't need anything
above like a 7-iron I need a driver for
it but no he didn't but yeah I hit him
really good at heart
yeah they gave me this like certificate
says you got a hole in one and I was
like I was I'll admit I was [ __ ] at golf
I was just starting I was like maybe a
couple months in and I hit something
clean and it rolled off the bank and
just disappeared and I was like where
did it go that's amazing
mm-hmm what a good time mm-hmm I'm
probably never gonna do that I can
barely hit a hole any golf no dude I was
a bad player so anyone if I can get a
hole-in-one like that anyone can get a
hole one literally all you have to do is
hit it in the hole you have to be good
to do that I actually want to go golfing
with you I'm not going to ATM mm-hmm
7:00 a.m.
stuff to do at 7:00 a.m. what are you
doing somebody I'm being unconscious you
have an appointment to be unconscious
yes
okay what about 9 am me don't let's
figure out a tee time that would work 90
maybe so we leave the house at 8:30 oh
but think about this you get done at 12
so then you're like ah the whole day I
have no problem waking up early in
general waking up to go golf I'm like
I'm having a hard time justifying it
what if I get coffee ready I like coffee
bagels ah okay I like this Sweden in the
deal yeah all right coffee and bagels
hot bagels like fresh well well you what
are you going to get fresh bagels bagels
they open up early they don't have
gluten free bagels that's not that's not
true there's glue free bagels you just
BYOC see bring your own cream cheese
yeah yeah well I'll get you we'll get
some nice hot bagels hop in the old jeep
head on over the course and golf miles I
have a set of clothes I have a spare set
I told you are they for short people
like me no but there's there they're not
too big to where you couldn't choke up a
little bit and be fine or we can get you
a set I understand I want to register I
think that's it can I wear rollerskates
absolutely not why not cuz that is a
liability no one will let you on their
golf course I feel like it's a missed
opportunity to have rollerskate golf
because they give all the walking that
you do if you could just like
rollerblade oh did you see that on
Twitter or someone posted a video it was
like a no it was not on Twitter it was
on Instagram but it was this golf board
it's like an e board but you can put you
go it's like a it's a new version of a
golf cart
so I guess electric skateboard for golf
courses you put your clubs on and you
just zoom around yeah but like why don't
we just my rollerblades when we golf
well how are you gonna swing your legs
are gonna slip out money and break your
neck
it reminds me of that kid every time I
think about like trying to do something
with rollerblades too reminds me of when
I lived in Cambridge and Boston I used
to just go out to the basketball courts
like over by my house at the park and
there'd always be like a bunch of kids
over there playing basketball like you
know 11 years old
but I'll play with you guys you know
this was like bored mmm didn't want to
play basketball
yeah sure we're playing knockout this is
what kid had rollerblades on and a
backpack like rollerblading so unevenly
like over to the fence to pick up the
ball and then he like line up with his
rollerblades in his back like there's
like 11 [ __ ] books in his backpack
like it's huge I'm like oh like don't do
it don't knock me out he's just like
slowly rollerblades up well I'm like
wobbling around and she's [ __ ] sinks
it oh my god you got knocked out by the
rollerblade kid with the backpack on
that's what I think shooting a
basketball with a backpack it's like
someone's like throwing you you better
at golf in your at basketball yes
I'm terrible we should want to be one of
basketball I'm so bad and I don't
understand the rules I don't understand
what a foul is what do you mean you just
can't hit you can't come in contact with
someone but see I'll do that and then
I'll like grab your shirt or something
and someone's like foul and I'm like I
don't understand what it follows you
grab their shirt why can't I grab a
shirt a foul
when you grab their shirt okay then why
can't I like push you you can't push
them because that's a foul okay then
what's a foul this seems to be a lot of
foul okay so more important question is
what's not a foul yeah okay what's not
it's all right quick it's not a foul is
when you come in contact a directly with
the ball or you have I can hold the ball
while you're holding the ball yeah
that's called a steal no so you have the
ball right now and I'm just grabbing it
from you that's called the steal I'm not
gonna let you do that but like I would
dribble I can hold it I can touch the
ball I'm keeping it away from you that's
what offense is it's my ball but if you
hold it now you're in trouble
well no I'm not in trouble I just can't
double Jill I can't dribble again I have
to pivot or pass then you're not allowed
to like isn't the call to carry or
something carries when your hand goes
under the ball while you're dribbling so
it's like you're you're doing that yes
so it's if you hold it put your hands
under the ball how is that not a carol
if you dribble it after your hands on
these are too confusing these rules are
too confused it's actually very simple
but you can't move your feet more than a
couple times cousin that's a travel you
can take two steps without dribbling but
then then what then the third step is to
travel but like what it you can just
stand there the whole case yeah you
pivot you stand there or you pass no
one's gonna just stand there there's a
shot clock there 24 seconds an offensive
timer to make sure you don't just stall
out and burn the whole clock every every
offensive possession you have 24 seconds
before someone has to take a shot and
then if the shot makes it you're on
defense and if you miss it and you
rebound the shot clock resets see this
is like reminds me of when I was a child
like I listen okay I can watch
basketball and enjoy basketball and feel
like I understand what's going on no
problem if I am to play basketball I
don't understand that's why I can't do
the things that I want to do I mean
that's a fair sentiment because playing
a sport is always way more confusing
especially than when you're watching it
has really football sometimes it's very
difficult for me to understand as a
viewer what the hell is going on
basketball I feel like I understand I've
watched football with you though you
know what's going on in football but
like I'm confused sometimes yeah some of
the penalties and little little like
semantics are confusing but you for the
most part can watch football go play
they understand what's going on I feel
like when I was a kid I wanted to learn
how to play baseball my dad was like do
you want to learn how to play and I was
like yes very badly teach me how to play
baseball there was nothing really
complicated for me to understand as a
child how baseball works because
baseball is the greatest sport like yeah
there's like weird little rules and you
know infield flies and you know drop
third strikes whatever like there's
stuff that you can learn or that as a
viewer you like I don't understand that
call yeah but if you're a child learning
how to play a sport super easy just like
soccer I feel like it's super easy for a
child to learn how to play soccer yeah
why is basketball it won't go into my
brain well it doesn't go in my brain
well question so when you first started
playing sports as a kid yeah did you try
basketball on a team yeah not on a team
okay I was so that's sort of I couldn't
maybe both I couldn't even play my
brother without getting in trouble
so that sort of might be why I'm saying
everything's a foul and I was like I
don't
he's six five what am I supposed to do
triple past them dribble past him cross
him over break his ankles you know I
think the reason you understand baseball
so well and it came so natural to you
and softball is because that it's just a
better sport oh damn boy that's toxic
you would put that sense is vacuum out
for you baseball's a better sport oh I
don't care you can come at me oh oh oh
do you disagree I think that they're
different sports no one's better one's
worse I don't I can't agree with that
said I if I had to choose one sport to
watch forever easily be baseball it's
very different that's that's that's
watching that's you just said a big
statement which was baseball's a better
sport it is oh he said it again they saw
such a good sport oh they saw such a
good sport it's so overlooked by people
who didn't maybe play it and think it's
boring and slow because they don't
understand a lot of the intricacies or I
understand why people think it's boring
and slow yeah I see why they think it's
boring but they're also wrong oh I also
just you know remember going into
millions of extra innings and my poor
mother sitting out and like the rain and
snow or whatever in any weather watching
us play for hours and hours thinking why
couldn't my daughter just [ __ ] played
soccer like everybody else well we have
a very set amount of time that's what my
parents were definitely thinking except
it wasn't raining or snowing same thing
it's like you go to your kids baseball
game and you're like yeah I'll probably
be done by like you know four or
whatever your own [ __ ] your whole night
dude my dad he's when I did travel ball
my dad used to drive me to the corners
of the earth see my mom was going to
Buffalo every weekend dude we went out
all I mean we grew up in Southern
California dude I went to places that I
had no business ever going as a person
who lived in [ __ ] Santa Monica in
Culver City never I went to Victorville
I went to like so far the [ __ ] out
they're all different
what is that what are you doing was a
big bill shut up with the baby okay we
went to a place called Field of Dreams
fine where they had little replicas of
pro stadiums
Little League size weight that's really
it was really cool that's we had a
Fenway they had a Wrigley they had a
Yankee Stadium
it was [ __ ] cool it was like a really
dope experience I was a kid that played
there yeah I mean and I don't even know
where the [ __ ] that is chino hills'
maybe that's not that far it was I went
I was playing on the team where I
remember my dad woke me up at like 4:00
a.m. to get going on the road it was
like a three-hour drive and at that
point I had known that my at that point
my dad was like ah [ __ ] up but they I
mean that's that's it for you when you
play baseball and softball as a kid like
your parents were just like driving and
driving and driving I mean for other
sports - that's not exclusive to
baseball and softball it's really cool
what was your favorite number you ever
wore in all of your time playing
softball oh I always wanted to be number
six six was my favorite number but I
wasn't six in college it was seven so
you finish with number seven but six was
your favorite number yeah damn that's
that's hella dope yeah word up what
about you
twenty-two was my favorite although I
wore 21 during my junior year and then
my freshman year I wore five but the
rest of the time I was 22 what about
your senior year of college I didn't
play past the first semester of training
during my freshman year I know it was a
joke
I know I'm just I'm just admitting it
I'm I was bad I did not play call
interface huh well I wasn't bad I was
injured I could have played oh you
petting my nasty feral boy this is fun
talking about sports yeah well this is a
sport you have to go please welcome back
to Jenna Julianne sports podcast well
you have to go play golf and settled you
do video that'd be a fun video yeah I
would do it we just need someone to film
yeah I got a guy you do yeah oh okay
great a guy cool
I know everyone's always like can you
guys do an episode of chopped and I'm
like we would need someone later party
taste our food like film us like we
can't film each other and also cook it
doesn't work yeah like a round of golf
we're both just loved up would be
hilarious I think okay idiom 9 hot
bagels and coffee bagels we but where is
it I don't want to drive like an hour no
it would be local cuz I don't want to
leave bunny may be local it'll be like
four hours money did not have a long day
alone look mmm okay gentle having you
shake his hand his nasty Farrell gross
hand
oh my special boy here's a special boy
well um yeah Jesus thank you guys for
hanging out and listening let's talk
about sports and whatever else also
sorry that this this year we didn't get
super spooky yeah considered maybe next
year also I hope you you're having a
great Halloween season I hope you did
some cool Halloween festivities over the
weekend and maybe you have something
cool plan for the 31st well I'm gonna be
streaming kind of all week there's a
whole new tarkov patch that I know
you're grinding so we'll see you guys on
the stream and see you next week for
another podcast but thank you guys for
hanging out and happy Halloween
see you later
[Music]
you
[Music]